we shove aside everything else important
in your life to bring you a highly
urgent news flash will make you angry
for free will show you stories of
incompetence and bureaucratic cock-ups
but will give you no outlet for your
rage you'll be wandering right at those
idiots just get themselves together but
they won't they'll carry on being idiots
and you'll carry on shouting your TV
like a maniac what taking to Twitter
like a demo if you're honest once we
finish showing you the tenth execution
and the sixteenth bomb blast a weariness
will settle in on you you'll be aware
you care a lot more about this than this
so add self-hatred to the list of what
we can do for you
we'll be careful of course not to
mention anything that went right the
couples who didn't kill each other the
sweet little girls who weren't molested
the extremists who'd thought better of
it took off the explosives and went to
work at IKEA once we finished with you
you'll have no more hope for Humanity
you'll be seeing murderers pedophiles
killers and lunatics pretty much
everywhere the only solution for you
will be to go shopping
commit a crime yourself or log on to the
next bulletin if you like our films take
a look at our shop the School of Life
comm forward slash shop you'll find lots
of thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you